Well. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
[inaudible].
Um, all right gene. I think, uh,
we're ready to start the show.
And you put your jeans on. I got my
jeans up. I got, how are they tight?
They're pretty tight. They're pretty
high. Teens are so tight. Yeah.
I put on a pair yesterday and I was like,
oh, I don't know if I can do this today.
I'm not there. This is going to be
a flat maximum, maximum gene edge.
Let's do it. Ready? Let's do it
before you have sex. If you want
to be horny for two or three hours,
like you never been in your life and
you have access to marijuana too good.
We'd listen to me.
Uh,
that go through.
Fuck yeah.
All right.
Take two.
Oh was Randy
will go to your mom's house,
Christina?
Yeah. That's good. I make beef type and
he goes like, beef writes like that.
Let me see what this is. Where it
gets you a lie. Yes. Tamar Braxton.
So this guy, what do you think
he's giving you? Sex Advice.
I don't understand what the advice is.
So he said,
if you really want to have super horny,
like a good horny time, he's telling you,
you got to get really good weed.
He's telling you this as he's a inhaling,
laughing gas through a balloon,
but now he's going to tell you the next
thing to really up your horniness ready.
Okay,
true. We'd along can get your
really hornier than normal,
but it's been on drawl.
Take about 10 12 bedroom girl before
you to have your sexual fun with your
partner or whatever you do or masturbate.
All right.
Well isn't that way too many? So
many. I think my heart would stop.
Wait,
does that make your heart?
I think also if you wanted to
tell anyone, hey, you know,
any medication is over the counter, take
10 or 12 of them and then go have sex.
Like they're all going to be like,
yeah, that was really more intense.
I remember as a kid, my mother would
give me Dimetapp you want to fuck good.
Take, take a 10 or 12 shots of Afrin
and your nose and then smoke weed.
All right. Crazy. Yeah. It felt crazy.
They're pseudoephedrine isn't there in uh,
in that, I don't know. Anyway, I used to
take Dimetapp as a kid. It's outlawed now.
It's gone. It is, yeah,
because it was loaded with like crank
and I remember it just makes your heart
pound but also had a downer so at the
same time so that you could fall asleep.
So I'd be like, but you can
breathe real easy. I don't know,
man. This guy, he's got to
figure it out. If you ask me,
I'm about an hour later when he fill it,
just kicking and smoke your weed done
and then go ahead and get horny and I
promise you it will be millions of times.
You'll be so blissfully horny
that you will not want to come.
Trust me,
it's gonna be restlessness.
If you take it really
late at night and you're,
and you wanted to just go to bed,
I don't do that will make you
have wrestle slaves and rubbish.
You'll wake up and you'll,
you'll,
it's not very pleasing what's going on
with laughing gas when he's out of his
sight.
Is he filming in his closet too?
But his pupils are super dilate
and he's like, he's giving you, I
like that he sold himself. You know,
this is how you do that.
The system,
you can tell he's really honed it over
the years. He's like, I used to do two,
three Benadryl and then four or five,
10 or 12 minutes ago,
God even come in the foil.
You got it. You know,
10 or 12 and then smoke your weed and
trust me there, you're going to be horny.
You're going to be all cranked up and then
you're going to want to bring it down.
Yeah. That's craziness, dude. It's a lot
better than an orgasm. I've been up
for like 48 hours straight before.
I'm an underling weed. I'm a computer
watching girl. Women wrestling.
Yeah.
Sounds good. Yeah. Sounds like a
good time. Women's wrestling. Well,
and it's better than having the orgasm
cause he's saying you're not going to
come now he's saying you're not going
to want to because you're so blissfully
horny. So you're so, so enjoying the way
you feel that you won't want to end it.
Oh, I see. You know,
you'll just want it to like keep riding
that wave and riding the snake. Yeah,
man. I'll kind of lives to, people
have, Huh? I don't know man.
It's a lot of free time.
It's a lot guess guys really worked out.
How do you feel by the way your,
your special has been well received.
It was pretty exciting.
Overwhelming.
It's overwhelming to have this
much approval. Like I legit,
I'm not used to people liking anything.
You know what I mean? You just,
you slave away in obscurity for 14
years and then and you're just like,
it's fine. I can say what I want. No
one cares. And then one day or like, oh,
people care. It's great. It's amazing.
It's a special amaze. Thank you. Well,
without, without you, my jeans would
never be so tight or high and I, yeah,
because you're my love
hearing my support system.
You're my family or everything
without you. There is no gene.
There's two mommies and one
jeans. That's how it goes. Again,
if you haven't seen it,
it's called a shoes with them
and it's on Netflix right now.
I actually had the song in
my head over the weekend.
A lot of no lie a lot.
It's not a bad song.
I feel like it's not that bad.
I mean, he can take some work.
It needs work, but it's not
bad. It's pretty amazing. Yeah,
like I feel like if the right band
took it and actually reworked it,
it would be very good.
We'd have a number of submissions of
people that have reworked it, so I'm like,
God, it's pretty exciting. We also have
this email. Listen to the latest episode.
It was my way to work.
You guys suck.
I'm walking around my office and machines
within machines within is stuck in my
head. I'm trying to focus at my computer
and machines within machines with.
It was like that juggle who tapped into
something inside of me. Megan stuff.
I agree. All right, Chris.
I was laying in bed last night and
you were supposed to be giving me head
scratchies,
which were inferior because I woke up
and my hair was not tangled and the whole
night I was going machines
with machines with this
whole fantasy about I had this,
I don't know, I do a lot of like,
you know Dimetapp Benadryl.
I do a lot of thinking.
I take like 10 or 12 Benadryl.
No,
but like you know like I'll come up
with jokes and stuff in the shower.
I always thinking the show this weekend,
him and I was on the road and I was
doing shows and then I was like machines
with the shower and I was like,
we should fly that guy out.
Bringing him to like a friend's
studio and like have a,
a real producer friend of mine
lay a beat and like film it.
And then one of my good friends who you
know is a music video director and a
video that was kind of be the most amazing
thing that ever happened to this man.
I think we should work on, you know, let's
find him. Does anyone know who he is?
Let's find him.
Do you have any contact yet?
Does anyone have contact for machines
within guy? Because I think that could be,
I think we need to make this happen.
We need to fly to La and we need to treat
him like a star and get his Korean do
machines within, you know? Yeah.
I think we could really do
something special with that.
But in the meantime, um,
some of our, you know, we are not a lot
of podcasts will claim, you know, they're
this and that. There are no,
there's no podcast in the world.
It has a better, uh, a
library and a better, uh,
musically inclined base than we do.
We have some of the songs, you know,
the songs that have come out of this show.
Some of them are incredible.
Like there's really talented
people making music. Anyways,
I actually was dreaming about
this too this weekend. I, I,
first of all thank you to everybody
and Arbor Indie and Northfield, Ohio,
Cleveland,
unreal shows,
sold out shows really fun.
We just had the best time,
Josh Tyler and I. Yeah. And like,
we had great, great shows, man.
They were just great energy. Never knew
Ann Arbor was going to be like that.
Did you meet anybody
after the shower is like,
did you take any photos of people or is
that just something a personality Cham
does? Uh, yeah, I took photos with people.
What do you mean was I nights I've
been getting reports when I'm in,
I was in Saint Louis teds and, and
in the south. And people are like,
Tom's not a personality champion.
Doesn't really meet people.
What are you talking about right now?
Yeah.
You don't think I took photos with people.
Why would you even say
something like on the streets?
You're not friendly or not a
personality champion like I am what?
But everybody was like,
you're so much nicer than Tom.
At least can get with
your fucking twinsie here.
These are like three versions of the
same person as the Cleveland Indians,
baseball players right here. Oh my gosh.
Yeah. Play the game all at the same,
came to, came to the show.
KIPP Zimmer right here. We, um,
hung out after the show.
Super Nice guys. Cool.
MMM,
yeah, I took a, if you go to my
Instagram, okay, you're on the gram.
I'm on the gram to the
gram and you do the,
uh,
you go there,
you can,
you can see all the pictures I
take with people they're posting,
but I have so many more
machines. Machines. All right.
So it's not a bad song. I
got slight distraction, but
MMM.
So here's just a few, but you can just
let me know. Let's see. This is a machine.
This is machines within featuring
Charro by DJ socks on to track.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Got It.
Then
what she needs, but she enjoyed it. Then
change. But then she changed. But
then it's a different approach.
Yeah. Yeah. Cause here's the
thing, when I hear, I hear
you say that he used to go that way,
but so this was just someone's take on,
this is kind of an,
it's a chiller chiller,
but also kind of scary or vibe
because it had like an Airy,
like horror movie quality
to it. I thought, yeah, no,
Charlotte
going, you know what
I'm saying? Yeah, yeah.
60 k 16 it's kind of scary.
Yeah.
Shit.
Six Gene [inaudible] Dan,
Dan home to share files machines was then,
but I feel like something bad's about
that machine. These machines are,
this could have been in this decaria
movie, you know? Right, right.
Come on up on the house.
Was she injured but take
like shoot 16 Benadryl.
She sitting the shit on a song
we street. That's cool.
I like it.
Oh no street. I like, I was scared, but
then
really good. I mean it's so good. I
should have done this to mind people,
but like this is what their work.
Yeah. I'm trying to sing
my song, my song. Oh, okay.
Here we go. Here we go. Okay. I
have another beat down for you.
I try to practice talk just
in my own song. Just my
introduction to my song. Yeah.
Coming at Ya. Here we
go. I'll sing it. Okay.
Okay.
Machines wear thin machine.
They've got a gun and got again.
There's all that going on. Terminating
her gun. Yeah. Yeah. Machines.
But then the change was
then trying to wreck my rep,
trying to make my rep talk
to someone with the flow,
trying to practice on my floor.
Sharing with them machines was cheese.
That's it.
Hearing my on the street.
I don't care if I f f the
hitters Fr the haters.
Waze say fuck though.
It's good. It's good.
Just needed a producer dude.
Change was then,
but she then
good shit socks.
I'm
Dj socks on the track man.
Very interesting.
Take on it. Very interesting
take on it. It's awesome.
I applaud you. I mean I can't
believe he, that's amazing.
It's amazing what people can do. So this
is machines within coming up here by
Equis. Yeah. Okay.
So this is another version
of machines within yeah,
a different take and um, yeah, just, yeah.
Mastodon.
It's also kind of chiller vibe,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah. I'm going to change. Oh geeze.
16 yeah.
Machines with
shoes,
with our students with churn rate my rate,
which would make hour chunk,
chunk.
Here we go. Here we go again.
Here's my song. Yeah. Gotcha.
Here we go.
Share it again.
16 it works. Man Does. Yeah, definitely.
She 16 popping out a week.
Terminators, wheat chunks.
What's real? What's fake
meat shrinks tomato machines.
What machines?
They got the gun and got again?
Yeah. Got It. Just mission.
Yeah.
Machines
again. What's t 16? I don't know.
I don't know what he's doing.
Like guns.
Uh Oh, I just remembered, by the way,
that's true because I had mentioned where
it was weekend I went to this place in
Ann Arbor called Frieda's. Bodas
Cubans. Not True. Yeah, he does.
Does, yeah. I swear to you.
A toddler restaurant? No.
What do they serve?
Their Brito Bandido um,
I think it ain't all bad
needle. What's it called? Uh,
that's Beavis is restaurant. What's it
called? Freedom by Tito. Sorry? I said,
yeah, I went here. Frieda,
but Tito's Cuban inspired street food.
Oh Man. Diarrhea to I, it
was so good, man. Well,
I looks, look fried egg on top.
Whatever your freedom. Anyways, uh,
one of the guys working there listens
to our podcast. Palm gas. Yeah,
this is our podcast, so you're
kidding. He, um, you know,
I ordered the Burger and the egg
and everything, but you know,
I was trying, I didn't eat, I was like,
I'm not gonna eat the Bun, you know,
that kind of shit. Right. Like when you're
like, you're doing your primal shit.
Yeah. Just trying to split
fucker. Anyways, so they, you
know, I didn't know that he,
he didn't say anything at first.
So I order and then I had a little
side salad and then a server comes out.
It was Tom and I go, yeah. And
he goes, here's your, um, uh,
Judas, you're fried us, like
with sugar and sauce to dip
it in. I go, uh, I didn't, I
definitely didn't order that man.
And then the guy goes to the palm guys,
I thought you would like to try it.
And then I was like, oh, that's very
nice to you. And then Josh Potter,
who's with me, I was like,
you know, I didn't order this,
but I'm not turning this down.
I just dove in.
It was one of the best fucking things
I've ever hot. Little Chucho Bites,
Hubbard and sugar and then a chocolate,
a hot chocolate dipping sauce.
I was,
I had cramps for 36 hours after
we ate it and we had bites.
We had, we both had cramps. I was
like, I gotta feel good. Later.
He goes,
well you ate just spoonfuls of sugar.
Like it wasn't like sweet.
It's like covered. Yeah.
It's one of the best fucking thing. You're
saying it wrong. It's just true. Right,
right. It's how you eat a Chiro
dude. It's just a Mexican pastry.
But their Spanish, sorry, this was the
Cuban joint. But yeah, in Spain, right.
I don't think there Spain,
Spanish from Spain.
I watched the great British baking show
and they look it up to those are from
Spain again.
Maybe you're right,
cause they go this week we're
doing Spanish. She rose.
Of course they can't say
shit right on on that show.
Spanish churros and they did the same
thing where they all had to do variations
on the Chiro shoe role.
Let's see,
a Trudeau or traditional, you're
right, you're totally right.
For once in my life. I'm right on
the fucking show. Fried though.
Fried dough.
It's fried dough and it comes out hot.
Don't forget that there is based,
you know what it is?
It's basically a version of a donut.
Right?
But they're covered in sugar and then
the new shit is they give you a sauce to
dip it in the restaurant. It's like
how we added Bacon to Brussels sprouts.
This generation,
everyone's dip in that shit and Charlotte,
can I tell you the best place to get a
tro to get your life all verus street in
Los Angeles, but on all Vera Street, one
of those vendors. I mean that's what's up.
They're all over Latin America now.
Anytime there's fried dough that
it's the best. Now in Hungary,
their version of the Chiro
is called [inaudible] and
it's only in the summertime.
You can get it and it's deep fried dough,
but then they put butter,
garlic, sour cream and sprinkle
some cheese on that bitch.
Get your, it is so good. It
looks like they said there's,
they don't know the origin of the story,
but they think that maybe the Portuguese
brought it to Europe from China,
China, so that the Chinese maybe have,
well they do because they have before.
I'll tell you I know this. When I did
it, the Chinese guy, Chinese breakfast,
they do a fried donut with
like a soy milk, warm,
warm milk. Another theory, your donut.
The Trudeau was made by Spanish shepherds
to substitute for fresh bakery goods.
Judo pace was easy to make.
And then of course,
I guess they brought it all to Latin
America because now you find it.
It says you find it in Peru,
Venezuela, Colombia, Guatemala.
So now it's everywhere.
Look at us and our knowledge and our
knowledge. Okay. Back to machines.
Within machines with machines with,
so this is must jeans.
Yes. Most genes within, listen name,
Benny Harper was listening again. If,
uh, if you need a reminder of what we're,
what we're going off of here,
it's just just
their shoes with them.
Machines with 10. That's it.
That's all these guys had to
work with. Maze. Here we go.
I must genes within chair.
We're on the right track.
I actually, I don't think
it's bad. Cut Him off.
Wow.
Crazy.
Walking down the streets,
walking down the streets,
walking down
the streets.
Yeah.
Wow.
Pretty good man.
You know that we have your mom's house.
We have fans that are actual real like
famous musicians that listen to this.
Yeah. We have a few. I would, I challenge
those guys if anyone's got some fruit.
I would love to see someone do machines,
machines within. Man,
that was really good.
Yeah. I feel like Metallica and
if they could cover it would be,
you know what I mean? Oh
yeah. I mean they could go,
I feel like they could come out with
a completely an ironic, that's what,
that's the thing. Here's, and their fan
base would be like, what's Jane's? Yes.
Because me the phrase machines within
his fucking really dope actually like,
oh, that's kind of deep and like, what is,
Oh yeah, I do something with a man. You,
the societal structures, whatever the
fuck that means. Sure. A lot going on.
Last,
uh,
last week you also were a scenes
with Joe Rogan's podcast was
what does Mommy's mean?
It was,
it was awesome. It's the first time
I ever did the show without you.
So it felt a little bit like,
you know,
on Seinfeld when Elaine would hang
out with George without Jerry.
So at the beginning I was like,
how, how's this? What I mean?
I've obviously everybody
call you guys jeans.
We had a great time.
Uh,
Joe is such an easy person to hang out
with and he's one of the most wonderful,
sweetest, which one's the
genes, funniest humans.
And we had such a great time. We had a
really good time. We talked so much shit.
Isn't that crazy by the way?
That literally,
I don't know if people
totally understand this,
but doing his podcast to promote your
special is more effective and bigger than
doing like a late night.
I know it's so many more
people listen to it.
It is bananas because I'm,
you know,
Netflix is having me possibly do those
circuits too. And it's like, okay.
But the truth of it is, the glamour is
though. That's the one people go, wow,
you made it under that.
But the ears and the
focus is in the podcast,
podcast world.
I've been getting so many tweets from
people that Joe Rogan referred me to the
special and,
and now it's like I'm very appreciative
to Joe for having me on as usual.
Very appreciative.
Mommies put your jeans up high and tight.
He's the sweetness.
Um,
so we had the guide obviously tell us
to take our bandage rolls and how many
have a 12, 10 to 12 and then when
it kicks in dense, smoke your weed.
Okay. Wait, let's, let's
go through it. Seriously.
You know what I realized
about sober October? Yeah.
Cause I'm going to go to hot yoga
here in a little while is um,
drinking and stuff is so much,
not a part of my regular routine that
I could accidentally slip probably more
than anybody else.
In other words,
I put so little thinking and attention
into like getting a drink that I'm the
one that could easily,
I feel like,
I mean we're already halfway through the
month, but easily someone could be like,
oh hey I got your beer.
And I'd be like, oh, okay.
Yeah cause you don't think about
it. Yeah, I don't think about it.
Like I posted a joke this
weekend after a show,
a potter and I went to a hotel bar and
I ordered a coffee and he ordered a
bourbon and I was like, Oh I think I'm
going to break. You can do it. And I,
you know, I drank my coffee, but yeah.
Well alcohol's not a big deal for you.
Getting high is not a big
deal for, you know, I know
that's what he was like, yeah,
but you're, you're not sober cause
you're eating, you're drinking coffee.
I was like, first of all, it was
decaf straight cause it was like 1130.
I ordered a cup of decaf just to
have it crank of something. But, um,
that definitely was not part of
our arrangement was like caffeine,
which I did by the way.
I did do no coffee for the last 10
days of the weight loss challenge.
That sucks so bad. I mean,
I mean, you're not Mormon.
This isn't the no, I know. I
don't want to do that shit man.
Caffeine isn't that bad for you. Yeah. I
feel like I couldn't live without coffee.
It's my, that is my one thing for
sure. Yeah. I can't go without love it.
I love coffee too.
We have a toddler.
How do you get through having young
children without drinking coffee? Yeah,
I dunno. It's fucking nuts. Nuts.
So, but, but Joe's off the weed.
He uh, he didn't do it. I mean, he,
he, people thought he was smoking weed,
but he's not, he's not smoking. No, no,
he's fine. He seemed totally, totally.
He's like, it's not party. Also, a lot of
these things were not hard for everybody.
For you too. Now there's two other people
in this challenge who are not thrilled.
This actually is much more
of a challenge for Aerie.
Bart,
they are there.
I can tell like I think Ari's
more troubled or bothered.
Well definitely by not smoking weed.
He's a really heavy weed
smoker. Smokes weed every day.
So that's definitely a challenge.
He hates the idea of going to this class
just because it's an inconvenience,
which I can say I totally understand
it is a major inconvenience.
Like where could we end this podcast right
now where we could be doing it later.
But I have this and I have a meeting and
I'm trying to fit hot yoga either like
I can go either before the meeting or
after. I'd much rather get it in before.
So after my meeting I can
come home because if I don't
then I have to go from a
meeting to hot yoga and then
I'm home fucking you know,
super late tonight. Well cause you
guys are also doing 90 minute class,
90 fucking minute classes and 15 of them.
It's a lot of time commitment especially
because you're not just going for 90
you have to drive there exactly what
to get your shit together. Go. Yes.
Now how sweaty do your nuts
get? It's an, I'm just actually,
it's when I'm done with class, it's
like I just got out of a pool. Yeah.
It's just I'm completely soaked.
Do you smell other people? No.
People are pretty decent,
you know,
I think they show up clean
and you're not right.
You don't smell people.
I think also because like the smell,
someone would be either they're dirty
when they got there or you'd be hanging
out there way out.
You know what I mean?
Like you wouldn't smell right away and
less like one of the teachers one time
pointed out like, Hey, if
you're coming to this class, uh,
you like a bunch of before, you're
going to fuck with people. Like,
so don't do that.
So it would be a jerk.
Don't be a jerk to take 10 to 12
Benadryl and then take this class.
It's super hard and see if your heart
just explodes. Yeah. Horny. I am
how Horny I am in Canada now I have to
tell you that I used to take yoga in
Santa Monica. Yeah. Like
a million years ago.
And I always noticed that the men,
there's really not great
yoga attire for men.
Like the women have all the accessorizing.
So all dudes are in Speedo, right?
Like it's,
it's a bad fashion.
They just haven't really
marketed it for men enough.
So I remember standing
behind certain gentlemen, um,
when they would do the pose where you,
you got one leg on the floor and then
one leg goes back and up towards the,
he's amazed, right jasmine? Yeah.
W where your leg goes back. So,
you know what I'm saying? So one
leg back, one laying on the floor.
And I remember seeing countless
nuts. Yeah, countless balls.
And it's funny the first time.
And then you're like, really?
Like you can't cover your nuts
for this class. Like, you know,
balls are a, yeah, I'm
lucky I haven't seen balls.
I've seen some weird dudes.
And then there was one day where these two
guys, I was like, well look, I was like,
the fuck is up with these guys.
And then it hit me that they were like
developmentally disabled guys. Oh.
And because they were doing like goofy
faces and they were acting goofy,
like they were just acting weird. And
then I was like, oh, I think they're like,
maybe the bus brings him here, you
know, as part of a program or something.
And I also noticed that the teacher
never like the teacher will um,
tell, you know, tell
people like our Laura,
you got to keep that
left shoulder aligned.
Tom Tried to roll forward further on
your head, feet stay on the ground.
But these two he never addressed.
And I'm like,
why isn't he addressing
these two goofballs? And then
I realized that like, Oh,
I think they're special. You
know yoga. Yeah, they were,
they were kind and one of
them farted and yeah. Yeah.
And then one of them like was just
playing with his shorts and like,
and then one of them just stayed on the
ground and wasn't really doing poses.
And I'm like, why aren't you like
as if somebody else, you know,
I reached for water ones,
not a water break, Tom. And I
was like, okay. So it's like,
why are you not addressing these
two guys? And then I realized, oh,
and one of them showed up in Khakis and
a button down shirt and dress socks and
we were all like, ah, fuck.
Because it's, you know,
it's 104 degrees in there.
Yeah.
And then he left and came back
and pajamas and I was like,
I dunno what's going on with this guy.
Like thick pajamas? No, like regular,
but like still no one addressed him.
Yeah.
So that's what you do though, right?
Give him a pass. Somebody of course.
But I was like, at first I was just
like, what is up with these guys man?
You can't really chastise them, you
know? No, of course not. No, no, no.
So they farted somebody farther.
Yeah, one of the guys farted.
Did you laugh? Of course. But I
kind of kept to myself. You know,
there's this like culture in,
in big room where there's not a lot of
laughing. There's no, it's all pretty,
you have to,
you know,
you don't really get that much
out of it if you're not focused.
So people don't have a
beak crumb. Oh, okay. Big.
There's not a lot of goofing off. Yeah.
That's so funny. Most of my peers,
often there is with was when a is
when Burt's next to me, you know,
like sometimes. Yeah, sometimes,
uh, you know, we'll do that.
I forget the plane pose where like
your arms are straight out next to you,
you know,
and then your and your legs are straight
back and I'll reach over and I'll just
like touch his arm or touch his hand
and he'll be like, he'll be like,
well then I'll just,
you know,
I pay attention to where the teacher
is and I do like little goofy shit like
that, but it's pretty serious. Wow. Yeah.
Have you had any enlightenment thoughts?
No,
not super enlightenment, but I do, I
do say it. I mean you definitely there.
There's some times you get emotional
and certain poses, which is weird.
It's interesting. And I do think, um,
you have amazing clarity at the
end of class. You know, if you go,
when you get through a whole
class, you're laying there, you um,
your mind feels very clear.
It's like you can make,
if you had to like make a big decision,
I would go to one of those classes and
think about it afterwards. Interesting.
I like that. That's exciting. Yeah,
it's good. It's good. I mean, I do,
I do see the benefit.
The only part that sucks is with the bet.
It's like you're just having like, you
know, my week is crazy this week. Yeah.
Right.
I sent you my schedule because I have to
go to all these meetings and it's like
I'm trying to figure out how to fit in
all these goddamn sessions. You know,
it's the time commitment. The time. It's
not like you can do it at home either. No.
You gotta go to the class. That's the
tough part. Yeah. Well you're all,
you're halfway through it. Right. If
I go to today, what I'm going, um,
will be numbers seven and
then I can't go tomorrow,
but I'm going to try to go
Thursday, Friday, Saturday.
I'm going to try to go three days
in a row, two to tack on a few more.
And at that point I'll only
have five to do, but I'll have,
I'll have enough days to hit
them now at the end of the class,
did they hand out some rings and
like bracelets are such weird guys.
And the guys are all weird.
The girls are weird girls.
Definitely weird girls.
But there's some normal girls.
Most of the dudes are odd.
Yeah. Yeah. They're awkward guy.
Man Bonds. There's a couple of
man button guys. Um, couple. Yeah.
Wristband, leather wristband guys.
All the leather cough, you know,
couple just Petrouli salesman,
you know, just weird dudes.
Weird Sharman guys. Um, come hugs.
There's no dude's where you're like,
like there's not a guy in there or I could
be like, you see the game last night?
Cause they'd be like, what game are
we talking about? The game of life.
I mean like, I don't
know. Would they will say
nobody looks like they watch
the game is all [inaudible].
All the guys like the God,
his twin activator guy for this.
A patch of the students. Yeah.
Some of the instructors are God,
his twin activators. Yeah. Or like I
can teach you how to come hug and yeah,
a lot of Vegan Vagina dudes and
now the girls are weird. How,
what's their style? There's
a couple like, you know,
the girl with like the third I think on
her forehead she wears like a Bindi or
something here. Yeah. Like a sticker,
a sticker like hardcore Vegan lifestyle,
you know,
just like real grungy of the
earth. Weird in that sense. Yeah.
Real spiritual where you're like,
Oh god,
you'd be unbearable to talk
to. Um, and then there's,
oh no, there's like some sweet older
ladies, so you know, like go into there,
you could tell like they're,
they're enlightened in life with age
right there, like wise kind of cool.
Some of them seem like they're
cool older ladies. Yeah. Um,
I mean you're definitely not getting
like a party girl vibe in Beek rum.
It's not like the class of Beckerman get
wasted after now. There's none of those.
There's nothing like
that in there. Sure. Um,
couple of Rehab checks for sure.
You can tell this is like part of
getting their life back together. Sure.
You could tell you like you partied hard
before. There's definitely some of that,
you know? That's cool.
Yeah, so that's good. Rob.
Rob. Oh Man. What if you started
doing that during be chrome? Well,
especially if you, the professor,
the on the Thailand Penis.
I'm like lamb penis was land is
exactly where I want to do it. You Know
Rob, rob, I wish, I wish you
had some advice for, for women.
I feel like it's very penile.
I cannot believe you just said that.
For people that don't listen
to this show regularly,
Christina doesn't get the folders.
She doesn't get these
clips they're sent to me.
And then if I want her to
see one of ahead of time,
I sent her to them so that she knows.
But otherwise the whole fun
is to play clips and surprise.
Christina upset me. Yeah.
And now he has female advice.
See, I know I'm on the same
wavelength. I feel like I entered.
I feel like I know this guy.
Yeah. Here's the rub up.
Guy has tons of rubbing ticks for women.
Isn't that great?
That is a nasty, I'm not even sure.
I want to hear you want to hear it?
Ah, so we have God. Okay.
We have the One lady to practicing
in the vagina because the vagina,
the vulva, the vagina.
When you're too loose,
especially with the delay,
they have baby.
Right. That's kind of
my problem. We about it.
And you see there were done. It's small,
right? When the baby has this big,
yeah. Yeah. After that
it's very loose. Right?
So you got loose posters.
When he's talking to this baby comes out,
you got to lose puss.
So then what?
So when they make less before them,
when they,
before they had baby, they
make lovely. So amazing.
So after that baby,
when they put the penis in,
the men put the penis in his hand
and I in or out because to lose,
they don't feel it.
I love his face.
Am I in or out to loose?
After we were like, am I in? Oh No,
you have to lose those
fucking no. A bear trap. Yeah,
it's a snug little.
It's like you got,
it's like you've got a little
mouse in there going, all right,
well we have to practice the regimen. The
exercise, we call it exercise, exercise.
It gets up for the
strengthening the vagina,
give him an egg and they'd practice
like clenched down on the leg.
You put the Shit Eric,
the Shag,
you should again, your pussy cover
the egg and shit and you put it,
you put that shit ain't shit egg.
You cover your egg and shit.
Pete Godfrey and the way we teach the
people in the workshop how to do exercise
when Barton, because a
woman, when this was done,
our loose the fest or wrinkle,
but this one type the first time,
how does that work?
That was the best, but he was like,
how does that work? But it makes sense.
Your face shutters as he asked
that question, watch Brian
all wrinkled, but this one tight,
the face tighter. How does that work?
Yeah. You stupid. Fuck.
Yeah, right. That's true.
That's a good question.
So what he's suggesting is you
take your shit covered egg.
You put it in your posts. When you're
pushed tightens, your face tightens. Oh,
I see. I don't know how that
works. It's all connected.
Your Vagina is the same as your face.
God dammit.
Free episode. Every
episode. Every damn time.
Uh Huh.
Because when you lose,
you lose.
Our life was all leak out because I have
flow or lie a big door in the window or
your door is leaking all the
heat out and look at week.
Ah, see that's why I'm so cold
all the time. My door's open,
my leaky doors,
energy door is open.
If you tighten your posts door
tight,
where do I get this shit? Egg? Is he
selling those at the seminar? We gotta go.
I gotta pay for this. We have video of
him talking about massage your testicles.
Rabie Dick 350 times and now
shove eggs in your pussy.
I really would love to
watch him make love to you.
I think it's amazing experience. I
is so nasty. I mean, it's different.
It's not like,
it wouldn't be like one of those hammer
like pornos where it's like some guy
like gorilla pounding you.
This guy would like really enlightening.
I think every year you're always hung
up on this technique stuff as if that
negates the fact that he is not like,
you know.
You ever watch that show
Battlestar Galactica? No. Backend.
What's a show that had sleeves stacks on
there? They're constantly stacks. Well,
the guy looks like a sleeve stag and I
can't get over it. Call me superficial.
Just close your eyes. But he let him say
you to a wonderland. They crept bid. Yeah,
but you the dollar. The concerned
about reduce the machine. You have to,
when a play that, again, I was understand
what he just said. The mental, mental,
mental already concerned about reduce
the medication. You have to reduce the,
reduce the menstrual cups,
reduced what? The Mentor, Mentor,
Mentor three men. Preregistration.
[inaudible] leaking comas.
Energy. Got To reduce my
menstruation. Yeah. How do I do that?
Here you go.
What will reduce the amount of dumb
reducing is the massaging the breast.
There you go.
Every month.
A woman wanted to have
baby or not have baby.
The body producing that every man.
Right.
And in a moment of producing the body
had to pee pee entity to make milk.
Right, right. Wait a
minute to make the milk,
but you only make the
milk if you have the baby.
He's not an understanding how this works.
You don't make milk producing the egg
guy. He's got his science
wrong. I don't know.
So I have to hold on in order
to reduce my menstrual flow,
to keep my energy,
I have to rub my breasts during and
put it on and put an egg in my book.
This isn't going to be a full time job.
So big time commitment.
Yes.
So
who is so book? Uh, I know, right?
It's great when these loose
the face Aringo right?
Yep. But see how nice and
wrinkle free my phases. Yeah.
You look like you have a tight pussy.
That's how you can tell
who's machine is like, yes.
That's a whole new way of
thinking about it. Yeah.
Actually that'll never leave my mind again
because it'd be like every time I see
a wrinkle face, I'm going to be like, God,
tighten your posts up. Your door's open.
Yeah. All the energy is leaking
out of your box right now.
Tighten your dog your door and then your
face will get nice and they'll be like,
what? You should bring this
up at yoga today. Yeah.
Especially if I see a wrinkled lady.
I'm telling you though, if this guy,
let's put this way,
if I took his technique and I was looking
at nice blonde lady teaching this shit
to people, I can get on like the
today show and be like, ladies, yeah,
you want to fix those wrinkles.
It's totally,
you got to tighten your visual with him.
They're just like, it's this a jerk off.
It's all about the packaging.
Yeah.
I feel like we've talked
about that with jokes.
It's like bits work from
certain sources. Sure. You know,
of course you got to from a
certain person, they can't.
I mean they can say it,
but it's not going to have the same
impact. Absolutely. Absolutely.
It's all about the shell, the
shell, your end. Definitely.
But I feel like I could turn that into
a seminar and really make a living.
Go do it.
Go make $1 billion getting women's
wrinkles go away and then you have that,
you know people so want the wrinkles go
away. That right away they'd be like,
I see them. Some of my wrinkles are
gone. And you'd have people testimonies.
Like I went to Christina's loose puss
seminar and I had wrinkles and now some of
them went away cause my pussy
is tied again like that.
We could sell those eggs till
yeah you have your Shit, Egg shed,
ag dip and Shit and put,
I mean he doesn't talk about Ken.
An egg just break in your box.
Theoretically when you squeeze an
egg on all sides, it doesn't break.
You have to have like a ring
on or something sweet like
you did in science class.
Right. As a kid, I don't think he means,
I hope he's not meaning a literal ag
that you would eat but like something in
the shape of one like one of Lj Zags.
Yeah.
Like a fan or son lives.
That's a big thing to put up
there to PR. I mean, Jeez Dude,
I dunno. He didn't know what the hell
he's talking about. Uh, bullshit.
He doesn't always talk.
We've been doing this for like 40 years.
He knows what he's talking about.
So when the lady, when when they,
when the egg mature the on up a lot and
he now when he's stuck and you don't
Trump don't do anything with it,
it become lamb and lump become
Puma and they become, we'll call.
I said, ah, he's just
sold breast cancer. Damn.
I didn't realize
I miss command, which she been
up to. I wonder. I don't know.
Do you remember we had the,
didn't we have that Kim in Mashup,
right?
Yeah.
She's like with what's the
rub rub guy and man together,
rap, rap, rap,
rap and my as hell.
I do say I put Eh Shit,
Eh,
in my heart say but China but China,
but dyna fat fat in this lovely house.
And when she said that, when she fell on
her porn, she goes, we are here today.
I liked that.
She did this lovely house
and I have to paint his dad.
I liked that we had,
um,
the Kim in the sheet,
he did a 60 plus MILF 60 process meal,
uh, PC, like a clean version. Right.
Then she did the hardcore version. Right.
She did the Youtube version so it
wouldn't get flagged. Yeah. Like the,
the advertisement for it. I Dunno why
they make them do too well to Lauryn,
the perverts on you tube I guess.
And then the real one is on the website.
That makes sense. Yeah. You want to get
you casting the net for all the pervs.
Yeah. You gotta have, you
gotta have them all there.
How'd you say,
and I'm here to film at,
this is such a beautiful,
um,
we CD with the first time
of ever experience in my
life with two young men and
they had big heart car.
This is the hardcore version.
Pluralize Mark Cox plural,
really quaint place.
Quiet place is really,
really comfortable with
a lot of art effects. Oh,
side of the house as well as elsewhere.
People are looking at anything else
really, really comfortable being outside,
especially with the two gentlemen
who really tweaked me very special.
Oh my ultimate goal is to
really get them to be really,
really hot and I feel that [inaudible]
Kim Allen on a lot to offer.
Yeah. Oh you do though?
It's my first time.
I was a little bit shaking.
Yeah. Do you think would be
worse?
That makes you shake?
It'd be harder for me to be with Kim
on or for you to be with this guy.
Oh, you would be key. You
would destroy him on why?
I feel like you would like her
cause she so she looks great.
She looks better than me.
Nobody was fit. Come on man. No,
you'd be, you'd be fine. He, this guy's
a troll. Command's got her shit together.
At least you think I could
make love to Kennedy.
You would make sweet love to came on.
I think I'd be way too gentle for her.
She'd be like, you don't pound
crowd then pow. I was like,
I'm sorry. You don't
want to hurt it. What?
Oh,
has house asking for attention.
She would let you put it in her butthole.
Oh, that would be like first move. Yeah.
She'd be like,
why are you doing with that?
Push right in there and get
back their peg, get back.
I go with it.
And really satisfying.
It's satisfying like my whole body with
my whole body because they're so nice.
Yeah. She's sweet lady
actually. Do you think so? Yeah.
And Save beautiful words. I feel like, um,
there are beautiful words
and I feel experience and,
and I,
I was so hot for them especially,
um,
on the scene that they
put their hard copy.
I mean to my asshole.
There it is.
I was so ready to come.
I feel like it's weird
that cause she's so,
she doesn't speak like she's ever seen
porn before. I know. It's like, do you,
have you seen the stuff that
you're filming? You know what,
that's a really interesting point.
And I think maybe not. Yeah.
I think what this is for her,
I really think she's one of
these people who at 60 was like,
I want a new experience.
Yeah. And heard about like,
well you can film it. And do all these
crazy things and she went for it.
I don't think she had like years of
watching it and knowing about it. No, no.
I think there's such a naive a tay there.
Cause usually it's the guys being like,
what am I doing today?
And then girls like,
well I'm going to spread my pussy and
these guys are going to come in my mouth.
And you know, they know the jargon. Yeah,
no she doesn't know this is really her
sexual lingo, liberation or whatever,
you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's usually a guy. Well you had that
clip playing the other day. We were like,
you're going,
these guys are going to come in your
hair and then you're going to massage it
and it's like a come shampoo and
you're like, actually it's right
some of this with you here alone
because what's going to happen?
All these guys are going to materialize
all over the place. Okay. Okay.
And then what? You go do it, do it.
Your face is going to lean back here.
Ashley's going to care.
You're like this right here.
This is going to put your
head back and the guys can do,
they're going to come up here and
they're to jack off in your hair. Oh,
so got to do where they're doing this is
keep your hat and Ashley's going to be
massaging the come into your hair
get and this is really good for you.
Good solid protein in the hair.
Yeah. Yeah. See that's the average
shoot film. Shoot. Yeah. And she goes,
we are filming today.
Like she really is nice things.
They were saying the artifacts from
yes in the house and she's like,
sweet lady caress my body. Like I
don't, I didn't see any of that.
And they're like, ah, I did get
granny. Like nobody's caressing.
Do they anything right? Hammer this lady.
Oh of course. That's the whole thing.
60 press mouth that you get
hammered gentlemen, gentlemen.
And I think she learned the gentleman
because of the gentleman's club, you know,
and like they call strip bars the
gentleman's club, which is always silly.
Like really like there's guys in
suits that are showing up. Yeah.
What gentlemen are coming here and
she probably saw a gentleman, right?
She saw a gentleman club and was like,
oh these are, these are gentlemen. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Like guys are interested in
sex or gentlemen, these are not gentlemen.
These are not gentlemen. Hate
to tell you. Uh, we'll just,
that will not act as for women
as well. Nice. And massage
the breast. Okay. Massage,
massage back forward, backward
and sticking the breadth
and pushing the breath.
There's the,
this is Adam is looking for what?
Cause he could teach you this and
he'll be like, yeah, like this,
like this. And you're like,
ah, yes. My Dick get hard.
Yeah.
People pay me $500 I
show up as ridiculous.
Show me the massage again.
It's crazy.
I want to say stop my stop back and
forward back work and checking the breath,
using the breath and
pushing them together.
And that helps you not get breast cancer.
Right, right, right. Just alluded to,
right. Right. To a fight. Breast Cancer.
I have to do it.
This is how 12 year old boys
imagine like girls playing.
This was a 12 year old boys.
Imagine what doctors do,
like when you go, if a woman goes, I'm
going for a physical, they're like,
I got to play with your tits.
Put an egg in your purse,
right? This guy's like, yeah, it's
actually very effective way to,
to keep a healthy body going.
What?
Is this all one interview or did
this guy come back for my debt part?
I don't know. I feel like it's gotta be
the same one and we just didn't absurd.
He just found out about it and in his
dad shoes. Yeah, those are Nice Nike's.
Right, but they're dead and
Nike's. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. Yeah.
The other dude's got on like dress shoes.
This guy just went for his walk,
his morning Tai Chi walk and then Kate
at the interview and you and the women.
So the women probably take three to six
months to learn all these techniques.
It's longer, longer, longer,
or they have to learn how to feel
the contracting or the uterus.
I can go out the uterus,
London Real,
you can watch their a youtube channel
and learn all about this stuff and it's
very, very good information. And
then I got to do my urine enema.
I don't forget that when these loose
the faced origo you go my urine therapy.
I got to squeeze my egg. I got it
was squeezed my boobs. He's awesome.
I got to take 16 Benadryl
and then smoke pot. Okay,
and then you have fun romp Africa. Yes.
I think it has got to be the same idea.
Right? Let's see. Let's
see. Yes. Now you'll do it.
You'll feel, oh really? Yes.
Orgasm without ejaculation.
So you feel so you see when you do,
when
you squeeze all guests.
I'm coming up the interviewer laughing,
but don't you feel like we should put the
Benadryl guy and him together? Oh yeah.
You're super horny and then
he's like penis like that.
You smoke your weed. Yeah.
Restless leg syndrome.
He massage like that.
We have two methods that could go really
well together if he just thought about
it and you throw a command in there.
I mean it's a perfect, perfect mix.
Perfect system. We've got the perfect,
the perfect smile. Perfect system.
It's really something Jane or up. What'd
you do? When I was going this week,
just rubbed my titties and
played with my eggs through eggs.
Firmed it all up there. You can see
how wrinkle free my shit is now. Yeah.
Hung out with a little jeans that
good. Ah, he's the best dude. Yeah.
He's Super Fun to hang out with the dogs.
I just chilled. I chilled really hard.
I needed to be home for a minute, you
know, doing nothing. That's my favorite.
I've been baking lately and I'm a terrible
baker because I watched that British
baking show and now I think I can beg,
but I, I just fuck it up every time.
But I still like it. You know, it's,
it's a good to do things. You're not,
you're not great at Joe Rogan.
I were talking about that.
He, he's, he does things,
he's not great. And I was like, Oh yeah,
I think I've started doing that now.
Cause it's nice to,
to enjoy something even though
you're not good at it and sure.
And also feel like you can try to get
better at it. So Lj helps me bake.
Super Cute and uh, and
yeah, go to the park,
run around, took some naps. Couple
of questions came in via email.
No boy,
conjoined twins who wipes with although
reason curiosity about how blind people
experience certain aspects of life.
I'm reminded of the mini taboo questions
I have regarding conjoined twins.
I identify as an amateur scientist
and according to my research,
most people wipe it the same
wipe dominant hand. Huh.
I'm curious about wiping
with conjoined twins.
Do they argue about who's going to
wipe or does one twin always wipe?
I appreciate any input towards my
research, but it must warn you.
Try not to go too deep down the
conjoined twin rabbit hole quick.
It gets pretty dark.
Thank you for all the work and congrats
on the awesome Netflix Special Christina
jeans up posedown Steven.
Wow. Well that's just,
I mean I don't think we would not know
but we can put it out there obviously to
the universe. Well now we've opened
up a whole other cannabis gets,
I know can join twins
questions. Very, very true.
I have so many questions for
conjoined twins. It. I mean,
when it comes everything,
everything. How do you do everything?
How do you decide what you do that day?
Do they separate people? How
does that even, I don't know,
but that's a great question.
God,
how do you like someone at the other
person's therefore it obviously obviously,
so you're always in an orgy.
Like basically you both
have to be dating somebody,
let's say theoretically and then you
guys were like, everybody want to do it.
Okay, great. Who, what
guy? I mean, I'm sorry.
Or girl meets a conjoined
twins. Look, I'm into this.
I mean,
I don't mean it to sound hateful,
but I mean really how it's too hard.
Just just
logistically speaking. Yeah.
You know, just because you're,
you're dating two different
people basically. And they,
they have distinct personalities.
So of course you're,
you're always dating the
sister and the sister in law.
Get out of that. How can you get over
that brother and the brother in law?
It's a lot. How do you
masturbate? How do you shit,
how do you also with the mash,
I mean,
do you realize that
they could be like that?
Like my conjoined brother could
be like a, it could be like, um,
I'm want to jerk off and he's like,
I don't want to turn it off.
Like I want to go to sleep. I'm tired.
I have a busy day tomorrow. Right.
I'm horny. No, and then
you have the same body
you're fighting over.
I guess in that case you let the brother
do the jerking and then you're just
like, well, I'm just ignoring this.
Yeah. I mean the whole, I don't know.
I'm so sad is that show,
the show obviously isn't on anymore.
Brittany and Sally whenever it was,
two different joints, but they don't,
they don't answer the important questions,
not any questions that anyone
wants to know. Of course
there their questions were like,
how do you guys deal with feelings?
And you're like, no, I wanted to hear
about that. I don't hear about blow dry.
How do you take a shit? Yeah.
How do you date? How do you,
how do you wipe God?
Yeah.
If a police officer has to handcuff
someone and that person is missing a hand,
what did they do?
How did they handcuff the mist from Dave?
That seems like something
that a police officer,
there's definitely a police
officer's listen to the show.
You must've run into that.
Yeah.
I imagine they would cut
the one hand is then you,
then you do the ankle thinks
they can't run away I guess,
but a free hand is too, you
know, too dangerous to have
free so like you got, yeah,
you got to handcuff it to something,
but I want to,
I want to know like if you're a cop
and you've ever been in that situation,
what do you do?
Do you stick his hand down his pants?
Why would he do that?
Just to be like play with it down there.
We can't have that out here.
Handcuff his hand to his dick and balls.
That's silly Tom.
It's very silly but it could happen.
Got All these great life questions.
Really great questions.
Important question about come hugging.
Hi Mommy's.
I showed some friends the
clip of the Com huggers.
One of my friends raised
an interesting question.
If somebody come hugs you without
you knowing or without your consent,
is that a crime?
How many Patrick rapers are out there.
Scottio and he's demonic. Wife Creep
me out. Thanks. Genes. Check, check
really good. And she is demonic. The, the,
the smile is horrendous on
that become huggers. So weird.
There are so many answers. Yes, of course.
That's, that's a form of sexual assault.
If you come hug somebody
without their consent, Tantra,
which helps us too,
the sexual
energy up our bodies.
So actually the longer we make love,
the more energized we get.
Right.
Such a Weirdo.
I want her and the rub rub guy and the
Benadryl guy and came in in the same
room, all of them. That's a
fun movie. Make that film.
And they'd be like, I really feel
like this is enough Benadryl.
And that dude be like, got,
have 10 to 12, 10 or 12
the whole movie would be about
getting people to take more Benadryl,
10 to 12 and now even that,
that Thai guy be like too many,
too many pills for five
B,
that's so many miles.
You cannot take that. You would,
I would have a heart attack.
That stuff freaks me out so
badly. Could you imagine? Yeah.
Half of that dose would kill me half
the dosage so much. It's so much.
You're so whacked out in your mind.
They're totally crazy.
You gotta be crazy to take that much.
No, you shouldn't do that as guys bad.
We should say that is bad.
It's so bad advice.
And then to smoke dope on top
of that, like what? I mean,
no wonder your brain's gone.
Your might,
your everything is shut down except for
your painter. This is, um, we brought up,
you know,
inappropriate parents talking about sex.
I was that you had this,
Josh Potter has great stories about this.
They've got an email. Someone said, Hey,
I was listening to your podcast for 17.
You brought up parents talking about
sex. I was like, also how like,
we never want to sexually
talk in front of our son.
It's so inappropriate to discuss your
sex lives in front of your children, uh,
to discuss any aspect of your
sex. Life. Person said wrong.
It prompted me to talk about
my 20 year long nightmare.
My father passed away when I was a kid.
My mom raised my brother and I by herself.
When I turned 13,
I started to notice my mom becoming more
and more comfortable with innuendos up.
Talking about the female anatomy.
I'll cut to the chase and give you
some very low and loose scenarios.
Here's quotes from her. I
sweat a lot during sex. Uh,
general talks about how when she
gave birth to my brother and I,
we destroyed her vagina one time when
at dinner she ordered a Sunday when the
server asked if she wanted a cherry.
She responded.
I haven't had my cherry and almost 20
years. Oh boy. She has since remarried.
A great guy. They will talk about her
sex life with openly at the dinner table.
These are just a few scenarios
I have dealt with in my life.
I agree with you guys. It is not
right. It makes me so nauseous.
I can't even eat moose soup anymore.
Love you.
Mommy's keep them high end type
Tom is the personality champ. Hm.
Yeah. I mean I I dated. He really
went through, right, right.
It's disgusting. But
my dad, not my dad. My,
I dated a guy whose father would
make sexual jokes constantly,
constantly. And that is just
weird. It's so disgusting.
Other kids' parents like that.
My parents were hardcore.
The opposite, right? Zero, right. Yeah.
I mean the most I got w I would
pick up on as I was older,
my dad,
but doing a dad joke to
another adult in other words,
like it wasn't for the kids.
Right. You know what I mean?
Like somebody would say a
couple of state troopers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. But it was like,
it would be like kind of like add an
earshot but never like to us or like,
oh yeah,
I used to get real hard with your mom,
like no mine.
Now it's also like now I kind of,
I'm guilty of like poking
and prodding them to get,
say those things, you know, almost 40
and I'm like trying to get it to happen.
You're asking for my mother.
When my mother passed away in 2015 we
were going through old photographs and my
dad, uh, texted me and sent me copies of
these photos he was looking at. He's like,
oh, you got a mom had great tits, great
ass. And I was like, oh, thank you.
Thanks for telling me. That's
why he married her. Good
tits. Good ass. Thank you.
Is that,
that's the last thing you want to hear
about your dead mom is how great her tits
in her ass were very attractive.
Thank you.
Your mom also had like told you
about sex when you were real young.
There is a lot of that. Um, she, I think
she thought she was teaching me. Yeah.
That's the thing is that she wasn't
doing it and like a perverse way,
but she was like,
you got to learn these things.
It was like she was way ahead of schedule.
I was about eight or nine or 10 and it
was like she was giving me tutorials on
how to please men and this and that. And
I was like, first of all, first of all,
this stuff and my mother's biggest
thing was having a clean vagina.
You'll have to keep your what Jina Glean.
And she had like that
old school douche bag,
like an old douche with like the big
red nozzle and the black and it was
disgusting. And then she would
uh, she was obsessed with,
you have to let your
vagina breathe so at night,
no underwear in the pajamas,
you have to let your vagina breathe.
Now my mother also weren't nylon
tights under her tight jeans.
So of course I think she
was strangling her vagina.
So she really needed to
let it breathe at night.
Sort of a curious lesson for an eight
year, nine year old though. Yeah.
And too early.
And then she had edible panties that was
the most disgusting and it was by her
bedside.
So I like,
I was privy to her nightstand contents,
you know,
like she would show me what
was in there and it was like,
this is being Yuck Colada
flavor. I'm like, what's Colada?
Like I was so young I didn't even know.
And then I got to taste the edible panty.
She like it was, it wasn't used or
anything. She unwrapped it and was like,
you want to taste it? And I
was like, all right, I thought,
but at the time you think it's so cool
because you're privy to like grown up
stuff. You're like, wow, a mom's
best friend. This is great.
I'm going to fluid bonded with
Jesse. Yeah. Yeah. It was so wrong.
Like you're never supposed
to be your parents friends.
Not even when you're an adult.
You're never their friends. Yeah.
You're always the child. I'm always
going to be, I should always be a child.
You're always my parents.
So nasty. Yeah. Oh,
it's so gross.
I taste you taste.
I tasted them and I remember being like,
this is not good. Uh, yeah. So gnarly.
God, so gnarly. It's
just the idea of the hot,
sexy man check leading my
life strangely turns me on.
That's my favorite part is the,
the nervous laughter that
accompanies these horny people.
They're always nervously laughing.
Like what the, the calm huggers.
It's always this nervous
laughter. Yeah. By the way, we
are always on the forefront of,
um,
you know,
weird speaking patterns and yeah.
We had that guy from Texas.
Yeah.
That was the weirdest
fucking guy ever. Yeah. Um,
and I ended up, he's all over Instagram
too, and he has so many fucking,
you know, uh, youtube subscribers,
hundreds of thousands.
But he has that crazy of an
arcade in Dallas, Dallas.
So weird man arcade and dedicate this
list to everyone who has been affected by
Hurricane Harvey Harvey. Yeah.
I Dunno how he learned to speak,
but his name's chills and I don't
know. So anyways, there is that guy,
um,
hurricane Harvey,
I guess the New York Times
named their first female editor.
Oh. And they did an interview
with her. She has crazy vocal fry.
Wait a minute, this is the first female
editor they'd had at the New York Times?
I think so. I think that's what this
is 2017, right? Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
But I mean, the Nanas chicks don't
even read and that's true. No, it's
meaningful to me that I'm the first
woman executive editor of the New York
Times.
Wow. Vocal fry. Cross generational.
No, and usually you don't see it.
You see it in the young women. Right.
You see it in the Kardashians
inspired women. Right.
I'm gonna go to the mall
and get some new maker.
I will say that I can go into it
if I'm just tired and I'm not like,
uh,
I almost said to me,
I know I'm not supposed to ask this,
but they'd asked me then
a gender related question.
I'm so proud of the fact that
I am the woman to hold this job
and I have been together
for nearly three years.
Wild. I liked it. His grammar was
proper there. He said, Megan and I,
not me and Megan.
So I am partial to that.
Cling to hold this job
that doesn't even seem real,
uh,
talks like that. This job. I've
never heard someone say that,
you know, you're the executive editor
for the New York Times and you go,
it's a good job.
I think.
Yeah,
the biggest challenge that I face as I
prepare to be executive editor is making
everyone in our news room as comfortable
with this transition that we're now
well into.
And I think maybe under my watch will
arrive at the other side and it's
happening.
It's hot fun.
I'm not saying shit bad
about the New York Times.
They wrote a nice article about me,
so I'm not going to say job.
Yeah, that's true. You were in the New
York Times not saying any of this job job.
Well, this, um, the
article is really good.
It's basically time shutting
the fuck up right now.
I'm not talking shit about
the executive editor.
It's about the mom lane in comedy.
Right. Ali Wong and I are now,
we're officially declared a movement.
Yeah.
It takes a no and a few
other women are doing. Yeah,
but you guys are really
doing something for it.
Um,
Steven Seagal is the latest to
be accused of sexual harassment,
but banana, it's like a 20 year
old harassment, but oh no. Yeah.
Then 1996, that woman, that's
who the picture was of,
remember I pull up that picture.
She was in the wrong file. She, uh,
was,
she wasn't to his house.
He summoned her to his house to read
for a role and she showed up with,
she brought a woman, a casting
director, whether it's the golf,
sat in a silk robe and watched
her do the scenes and yeah.
And he said, and then that same
day the manager called and said,
[inaudible] God wants
to offer you the lead,
but you have to go back to his home
for a private rehearsal tonight. No,
and she didn't want to do it.
So they offered her like a one scene role
instead and cut her from the movie and
she said on set,
he would be like around guys and
look at her and snicker and you know,
wow. Yeah, there you go.
I am the king of Improv is for free.
It's so, it's so odd. I mean,
he's usually such a normal guy.
Like there must be a new movie with him
out by the, because people keep sending
me clips of a new movie,
which is,
it's like breaking down
all this legal walls
that we thought existed.
No, wait a minute. Is it on
Youtube? Do we have a trail?
I think it's on, I think it's on
Netflix, but no. Well I think so.
All his movies end up there, right?
We've, we've watched a few on there,
but I think he's got a new one where,
let me see if this is Tiki
Punch in the raper. Yeah.
His new one looks like a real
hot pile of shit. Um, look,
I fucking just pulled up my
fucking in fucking oh no.
Look at that. In Aries there
too. Airy fairy Shaffer.
See Steve. I'll see if he's
got a new one. Steven Seagal.
You say that's not how you say
it. I say Steven Seagal. Seagal.
How do you say it when he was sick?
Tommy, right. Say Sea Gulls. He Gal.
Gal wasn't asked to goal Segal.
Steven Segal even.
He's such a weird dude,
man. This whole thing about he
lives in Russia now, right? Yeah.
I don't know if they're alive.
So weird.
Is it this guy? These
guys, so many movies.
I mean, are you American or not
buddy? You got to choose a side.
You with the commies.
Are you with us man?
Asian connection or we watched that one.
Asian connections. Fantastic weapon.
One Star.
Go ahead.
Uh, Asian connection. Good man. I
feel like we'd looked at that one.
We looked at that one.
Yeah. Is it code of honor?
Is this the one maybe
that he's [inaudible]
well why do all these tower title
sound exactly the same? I don't know.
It's like Asian Guinea pig shit,
code of honor,
man of words or whatever.
They're all the same.
They sent me the, there's this scene
where he's clearly, cause you know,
he's like really good at Improv.
He clearly is improvising
with the actress. Oh.
And it's so painful.
You know like poor girl is just like,
can I just stick to the
script and he's like, you can,
I'm going to fucking just
riff. It's so terrible. He's,
he's just the worst. Um, but yeah.
So now he's the latest to be
accused of uh, harassment.
Great. I love it. I hope
this trend continues.
I would like to drain the showbiz swamp
of these creeps. That would be fantastic.
Yeah. I wonder who we're going to
find out is the next big creeper.
Cause you know, once it,
uh, once the can is open,
once it starts make Hollywood Tan.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute. Did you see
how dark his skin is? Yeah,
Babe.
What you give your life to save the world?
The world of course.
Dump Shit Babe. He's like
Brown. There's a real actor.
Like I'm gonna try to act different
and you're not telling me
to take a look at his hair
is crazy. Come on. No, he's, he's so dark.
The Iq can't, I can't even get over.
How's Brown? His skin is news new Pale.
He's normally very pale. He's doing news,
new stuff. Every movie. Keep it exciting,
man.
He's like that lady on the
Maury Povich that we played.
I remember the Maury Povich lady
who went black with the injections.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. He might be doing that.
You might be going towards that.
I've been black now for over a black.
I'm like, wait a minute.
No you're not. Yes I am.
I wish someone had told me what that
fucking mom black was because it was an
amazing African American my whole life.
He goes like, I love the fucker cookies
and serious seeing that he just, Oh yeah,
yeah, I love the fuck out of cookies.
And we know that.
Yeah. If anybody knows the scene
or the movie that, that that's in,
I would really love to know is it
looks like such a pile of shit.
His acting is really questionable.
I mean that was like,
that is what I thought. Like he doesn't
even try. I know. Let's see if yeah.
That that poor other actor was
actually trying to react and,
and have a moment and, and Seagal is
just like, Eh, it does what I'd done.
And then, then, then he's a weird,
yeah, he's very weird. A weird
dude. Very weird guy. Um,
lastly, before we get out of here, um,
just thought that maybe you
would like to check this out.
Maybe it's a direction you want to go.
And as a parent,
Sweden is the most forward thinking
country in the world when it comes to
questioning gender.
The gender neutral Pronoun Hen is now
commonly used by my sweet.
Yes. I love it. Yeah.
So just arrived in out of blue in Sweden.
I'm about,
it's going to be a family here attempting
to bring up that kids free from old
gender norms. Hey. Hello.
How are you?
This is nick.
Go.
Yeah.
What answered the door was that you'll
see and not to be gender normative here.
You'll see hen and answered for sure,
man.
Well, Mama, is that your partner? Yeah,
my pilot and he goes by Matilda and Matt,
but is also the one who gave birth and
that's just what felt right to me because
I'm intersex.
I was born with characteristics
of both male and female. Okay.
Oh Wow. Yeah. Got It all going on.
Dell is an American photographer.
He moved to Sweden for love.
Their work has for over three decades
focused on queer identities and
challenging gender norms.
Yeah.
This is Nikos Room on how old this Nico.
Nico is two and a half.
I'm Mayfair is
a almost five and a half.
Mika and Nico were both assigned
male at birth and this family,
the sex you were born with does
not dictate your gender identity.
There you go. We could have done
something about that ourselves
to those were born with male
characteristics. Those two,
those two were, sorry,
born says gender males.
I think so. Right? Is that what you heard
and not just that third born though?
Is that what you heard him saying in the,
that's what the, that's what they said,
right? Yeah. Yeah. They're born male
and then they're being raised age,
gender, age, gender. Could I do,
we don't gender toys. We don't
change your colors. So what happened?
They're interested in,
it's like they can just play
with whatever toys they want it.
And you would never dictate what
last squat? No, absolutely not.
So they both have a lot of cars.
Interesting.
But interestingly enough, she opens up
two drawers and all I saw were trucks,
cars, Legos, traditionally boy things.
I mean could that be because they were
born boys and Bro, I don't want to,
I don't want to be insensitive.
I was worried about with clay thing.
Now Amica is for the past two
months has worn a dress everyday.
Just about when me is wearing dresses and
because Mick has very, very long hair.
Most people assume that me because female,
which is, well wait a minute, but that,
wouldn't that be a gender norm?
For instance,
the long hair, he, she,
they had just said the long
hair is traditionally feminine.
So isn't that a gender norm thing?
The TTC,
such probably what happened
was that the child,
so I don't want a haircut.
Oh, my hair to be long. Okay.
We use he for them.
Sometimes it's mixed and it depends,
you know,
because in Sweden we have hen the
gender neutral pronoun in Swedish,
I think Mika has always
said when I've asked,
it's been she or Ken.
Oh, there you go. Oh, so sorry.
So the child is asking for she or hand.
Well then there you go. Yeah. Then,
then that's what the kid
wants. And you, you know,
you're the kind of leading comedic
voice. How dare you, don't you dare,
don't you dare. Don't you
dare get me to be the, uh,
the, the, the binaries. You are
a lot. Oh boy. You're that comic.
Now people ask me about the
first 48 and bikes and shit.
Oh wait, what's, yeah. Yeah. You're
the person. I mean, I don't know. It's,
it's uh, I will say that just
watching our kid, uh, he's sorry,
and they've been,
our son has been privy to both
dolls and trucks and bike,
whatever leg I was.
He doesn't really care for the
dollies and it's not me being like,
don't touch the dolls homo. It's not
that. It's that he doesn't care. No, no,
it's true.
It's pretty.
And he likes dirt and
trashcan playing and stomping,
stomping him like it's pretty,
it's pretty gender specific.
Loves it. Yeah. Yeah.
Well,
how do you avoid gendering?
Your children didn't choose
anything bit gender neutral names.
We chose not to know what sex they
would be assigned when they were born.
Not answering the question.
Is it a boy or a girl to avoid
word and the g,
the B word and the g word.
How do you avoid knowing the
gender they were assigned at birth?
What does that mean? You
don't look at their genitals?
I think knowing beforehand.
Oh, oh, caring that the
home for a boy or a girl.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right. All right. They
would be assigned when they were born.
Not answering the question. Is it
a boy or a girl to avoid? Yeah.
Well the word and the g. What do you do
when people say, is it a boy or a girl?
So that's the answer. I would like to
know what, what is it a boy or a girl?
I guess it's up to the child now.
Here's my thinking here. And maybe this,
how do you handle a sweet old person?
It's like boy or girl. And they're like,
why don't you mind your fucking business?
Why don't you respect it's pro down.
It's a hen.
Yeah.
I think I also think that it sounds like
this person was had to deal with a lot
of shit growing up, being both
genders, the intersex person.
And that's gotta be so horrible
to grow up with your whole life.
But since you were fucked with and
your kids probably wouldn't be,
it's good to push your trauma onto them.
That's a really good thing to do.
Your two kids that were born as boys,
you should definitely be like,
I'm going to push my
issues on. I mean, yeah,
and I get the how painful that must
have been for them because that sucks.
It does.
But to go this far with this stuff,
like maybe you just need to
see a third first and then
changing pronouns in book
instead of it always being mama.
We say Mama and my par,
the Natter Sweetie Act.
[inaudible] it's so dark.
Yeah.
I want to know how grandma Margaret,
of how her grandchildren are being raised.
So she's a normal sheet,
but which one is her son?
Is it the one that they've
been interviewing other,
the other parent, right. No, because the
other parent is the one that gave birth.
So the other one is a female by,
so that would make sense that that person
would go to kindergarten and address.
So I'm thinking it's the one
that's being interviewed. Right.
But then she did have a normal
old person response was like,
it was fucking weird. Yeah. Yeah.
Meaning like I've adapted. Yeah.
And that like my own son was not
allowed to do that. Yeah. I mean, look,
I, I do feel like this stuff,
these countries are generally
more progressive. Yeah.
There's a lot. This is a lot
healthier society to live in. Yeah.
And then we catch up to what they're
doing in like 30 years. Yeah.
But my stupid 41 year old brain is
still just like, wait, what? Yeah.
Like I'm not sure. Sure.
I'm fully compensated.
They have like a way healthier, I dunno.
Like criminal justice system. Yeah.
Healthcare all,
all that is way,
way further ahead in Sweden and then,
yeah, that whole region really. Yeah.
There variant than Netherlands, right?
Isn't that what that's considered? No,
I don't know what they are. Yes.
Scandinavia. Yeah. Um, yeah, they,
they tend to be way more progressive than,
you know,
in terms of the Western
world and what we are at.
I mean,
the reason I liked [inaudible] so much
is because she thinks I'm a great mob.
Pop right back.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Well, it's interest.
Thank you.
I know where this one or this one.
You want this one?
Okay.
We're going to go with the red and
black theme today then. Good idea.
See how many,
on the other hand too,
it's like you also are shaping
how the kid responds to stuff.
You know what I mean? Yeah. So it's like,
is it really something that's originating
in them or is it because they're
watching you do your mob hot?
True.
Cause kids will just imitate what
the fuck outta you, man. Yeah.
Yeah man,
that's really, it's an interesting, like,
it's a really interesting question to
ask if you're a parent or just interested
in how these things work
because the kid does all kids,
especially when they're around you a
lot, your own kid, they just go like,
you start seeing, they'd start, behave
really doing things like you. Yeah. They,
you know what I mean?
You see the way that our kid picks up
the phone and he's like, wow. Yeah.
So I was talking to the phone and kind
of like imitating the way I do it. Yes.
It's just they do what you do.
They do do what you do.
It's fascinating. I do pawned, and again,
that's not something I always have to say,
but it would be good to know today
for the film [inaudible] Ella,
him just Mikko.
Okay.
See I'm then again, are we,
is this a lot of, let's see,
that's a big decision like for us,
such a small person personally. Yeah.
What do you want your Pronoun to be today?
And the kids like how about
just call me by my name?
Doesn't that also rattle their cage in
terms of who their self is every day?
Right. It's like, well
maybe this kid has a, uh,
an internal compass that's pretty
sturdy and you're now you're,
you're constantly forcing the
questioning of that compass.
Maybe that kid doesn't have the
same stuff you did. Right. You know,
like maybe your confused
but your kid's not,
and then you're making them insecure by
being like, well, what's your pronoun?
What's Your Pronoun?
What'd your phone like?
It's such a heavy thing
to try to break down.
The person that would best answer
this question would probably be
truweight alone can get you
really hornier than normal.
But it's been an Andrew
will take about 10,
12 Bannon girl before you want to have
your sexual fun with your partner or
whatever you do.
Oh,
I feel like 10 or 12 drill would
solve the world's problems.
I think that if you gave that
kid 10 or 12 vendor on your like,
what's your pronoun? You're like,
I can tell you now and forever
it's fucking hen. Okay.
And then that's what it is.
Hey, there you go, gene. Um,
we got to go.
This is a
our song murder. Bonar bye. Big e. Um,
thanks for listening. Of course,
a reminder check out. Um,
Christina special mother fear.
You're on Netflix streaming now.
I also found out that my first special
completely normal is now available on
Amazon prime for free. You can
stream it there. I have Amazon prime.
You can just press right
play on it. So I just found
that out. Um, and that's it.
That's what we got. Jean.
Thanks gene is a fun episode.
There was call me hen hen too.
Okay.
See you guys next week.
Going to put my agan.
I'm going to murder you. I'm going to,
I'm going to, I'm going to murder you.
Really quiet.
Sometimes when you stand next to him,
I just put her into his head sometimes.
What's going on in a minute?
You're a psycho. You. If you spot
another psycho, you're psycho. You.
If you spot another cycle
and the victims is a blonde,
one year old mother of one son named
Alice lived in a suburb of California.
Now Springs.
Police are going to
kill it.
Kill it,
Kill it.
Don't you like from the
stories? Yeah. Yeah.
Don't kill, kill, kill
dark demons inside
naps the hookers
and
he snaps the hookers
inside.
Even man that got his legs crashed.
I mean
the fact that the car kept going
back up the engine, the rabbit that
guys,
how to say words and pain
can fashion
is a murderer.
You're laughing at true.
The suffering that gives you the tickle.
You think that's crazy. Really? I mean,
everyone gets excited about something.